you can be patient if you figure out
what to do in the meantime ideally the
thing that you do in the meantime builds
towards the goal but I think it's way
more important that it just not detract
from the goal it's like by digging up
the plant wondering why it hasn't grown
yet you keep restarting the clock you
don't need to water it more sometimes
you need to give time time God I want to
plant a plant right next to the plant
because then it's going to start
competing for resources but if I want to
like play Frisbee far away from the
plant when the sun is shining and it's
already been watered and not already
been fed then that doesn't detract from
it and then when I need to go feed it
again I've got time to do it Charlie
Munger said that the money isn't in the
buy and it's not in the cell it's in the
weight